je vais vous parler de ces gens qui sont
prêts à boire de l'uriné soigner nous
avions eu la toque était venu boire son
urine journée rêver c'est quelque chose
de très sérieux c'est pas assez répandu
puisque il ya des millions de personnes
dans le monde qui le ferait et c'est ce
que nous explique un documentaire d'arte
est diffusée cette semaine des millions
de personnes dans le monde doivent leur
propre urine voir sa propre urine est le
reflet d'une longue tradition des films
x a été considéré à travers les âges
comme un moyen de rester en bonne santé
la meilleure partie de la miction serait
le flou intermédiaire entre le premier
jet et les dernières gouttes
ce matin j'avais un petit mal de tête et
comme d'habitude j'ai vu mon urine et
sept minutes après mon mal de tête avait
disparu fin des grands secrets des plus
belles femmes du monde et qu'elle prenne
une serviette trempée dans l'uriné et
l'appliquent sur leurs visages en le
laissant en place 20 minutes avant de
prendre leur douche
ceci ouvre les pores pénètre des sept
couches d'épiderme et nettoie tous ça
régénère tout en apportant un éclat de
santé à la peau se pisser dessus serait
même bénéfique
[Rires]
on a fait quelques petites recherches ne
produisons en moyenne en moyenne il y en
a qui sont un peu plus que d'autres
trente-huit mille litres d'uriné au
cours de notre vie soit la contenance
d'un camion citerne
alors est ce qu'on boit ce camion
citerne ou pas qu'est ce qui est ce que
vous estimez que l'urinothérapie a des
vertus est ce que vous y croyez d'amiens
moi je pense que ces personnes qui
boivent leurs urines sont des personnes
qui m'ont trouvé que ce moyen pour
attirer l'attention sur eux parce que
bien fait de l'urinothérapie relève du
mythe parce qu'en fait il n'y a aucune
étude scientifique qui montrent que ç'a
un impact sur la santé
donc à partir de ce moment là c'est un
mythe est à prévoir dans la croyance
donc on y va où on n'y va pas sûr qu'il
ya eu ces composés bien toxines qui ont
été rejetées par votre corps donc
pourquoi les régularités je vous avoue
je comprends pas bien mais tu vas être à
côté sur tous les sujets je suis pas
d'accord du tout avec lui et ne mangent
moins d'être jugé bon par dont vous
vivez votre pays vous non je vois
beaucoup de choses mais tant et si bien
dire en l'état veut dire que vous vous
estimez que
on a beaucoup d'études qui ont prouvé qu
effectivement c'était bon pour la santé
d'ailleurs je suis très étonné qu'ils le
fassent la bascule de scientifiques à
pardonnez moi qui prouve
oui voilà il ya beaucoup de médecins qui
le préconise donc moi je crois plus le
médecin que mon petit damien canivet sur
la très connue
et deuxième chose que moi pourquoi ne le
fait pas alors que c'est gratos et en
plus je vois pas pourquoi tu dis oui et
il essaye de ne pas tirer leur
l'attention parce qu'ils le font parce
que tu sais il invitera par tout ça
c'est qu'ils arrivent pas au café
excuse moi je conçois mais on l'a vu
d'ailleurs éclat d'enquêter sur ce
bateau qui est absolument charmante mais
ces personnes qui boivent laurine le
dise je bois mon urine ça fait un peu
cool c'est à dire ça y est ma qu'elle
découle de dire ce que vous en pensez
vous alors moi je pense effectivement
que dans des cas extrêmes ça peut sauver
la vie aussi on a vu des gens chez pas
perdu en pleine mer bien sûr ah oui
d'accord parce que je me disais dans
quelqu'un extrêmement simplement sauvé
ma vie parce que par rapport à ce que
dit mon petit camarade de jeu qui est
totalement à côté comme le disait emilie
il ya 95% d'eau 1 dans louis n'y a que
cinq petits pourcents de toxines donc
c'est pas toxique s'est passé pas pire
quoique que de boire autre chose en
revanche si on me prouve qu une des
vertus de l'urinothérapie koweït serait
aurait des vertus amincissantes
écoutez moi bien madame bin quoi je me
mets mes deux suites à boire vous le
jure que vous êtes dingues
non parce qu'il ya quand même quelques
vertus pardon plus tard j'étais jeune ma
mère m'avait dit mais les premières
jurine du matin et demain contre l'acné
et je pars dans là je bougeais tu me
l'as se faire la bise mais je me suis
dit mais ça veut dire quoi vous vous
trompiez pas un petit coton tige dans
votre urine et vert darty coton tout
seul
et puis à genre sur les petits boutons
donc donc une baisse dans les sondages
où je les fais je vous jure c'est vrai
maman pardon je je je délivre nous donne
raison à venir sur le secteur grand-mère
qui existe et je voulais en aucun moment
vous allez dire votre main votre maman
elle m'a dit écoute ça fonctionne
j'ai testé et j'ai vu que ça
fonctionnait dix minutes évidemment ça
allait on reste 10 minutes et après je
me doutais tout simplement d'être ces
gens c'est vrai c'est vrai tu as des
vertus thérapeutiques moche et méchant
thérapeutique mois un blocage pardon
psychologique pour boire mon puppy mais
je sais que quand j'étais ado je sentais
des pieds mais je vous dis c'était une
armée
nathan attendait c'était une infection
et on m'avait dit ce remède de grand
mère où je sais pas de faire pipi dans
une bassine voilà et de tremper mes
pieds pendant un quart d'heure dans têtu
les pieds mes pieds trempés les pieds
dans l'eau pipi gesell avait machin et
depuis j'ai fait une fois vous le faites
une fois la revue des pieds mais c'est
parfait si je peux me permettre les
stocks maison sous les bras
[Applaudissements]